LaShonda is in winston-salem hi LaShonda
how are you
Condes how are you today better than I
deserve what's up in your world
hopefully I'll be doing my district
screaming turn so good yeah I'm the
reason for my call today is that I'm on
the I guess the the baby steps right now
right now I'm still on baby step one but
and I'm a college student and I have
three children and right now I have
transitioned to move back with my
parents
and I'm going to school and I just got a
job so I was just wondering is it better
for me to continue my um like continue
staying here with my parents and like
like go hard on my on my baby Fitz or
should I since I have a job now so I
moved back out and it'll slow my you
know slow it down because then I have to
pay rent and all of that so that's my
dilemma so much of your money as a job
it's only ten dollars an hour is it's
for the year it's sixteen thousand nine
hundred and forty four tops
how are you feeding three kids on that
we budget which we budget very like
sometimes we have to do the meals by the
day because we have to sometimes I just
don't even want to spend money so yeah
it's just well you don't have a lot is
your mom and dad feeding you - um they
help they help with a lot of like
daycare like watching the kids while I
go to school and go to work and stuff
like that but what are you studying
Newell accounting when will you complete
that it'll be I just now started this is
my first semester that so I still have
four more years you have four more years
yes well not four more years but since
the the semester just started so I still
have four years basically
yeah okay so if you move out I'm not
positive you make enough to pay rent and
food with three well then I've been on a
waiting list for the housing and they
called me back but at that time I didn't
have a job so I had to wait until I
actually had a job but I'm just feeling
like if I if I do that then that's
really going to slow my dish snowball
down and I'm so how much do I gotta go
um forty-five thousand what subtle old
student loans repo just that that
because I was married and then now I'm
divorced so um and I did South apply but
it's it's really not a lot at all it's
only two hundred and sixty two dollars a
month all right you said you're on the
list for housing you told my subsidized
housing yes okay and so how much would
you have to pay for housing I think if I
paid she said three hundred and sixty
dollars per month but but then that like
I'm on my budget that I'm doing every
month I only have like that much left
over and I won't be able to really doing
I'll be stuck I was I mean but how long
how long can you stay with your parents
as long as I like to as long as you know
is as long as I'm doing like what I'm
supposed to do like positive stuff like
going to school and making sure that I'm
moving in the steps to get a career
going then I can stay as long as
possible
okay so they're supportive as long as
you're as long as you're being smart
okay yeah that's good I did it out like
I just felt like it you know I I hear
you say well you shouldn't say it home
with your parents well that's a little
different situation you don't have much
income and you got three little kids
and and we're trying to get your future
aligned that's different than a 29 year
old single person living at home just
because they don't want to go out on
their own you know making making $50,000
a year or something now so yeah I would
stay there I also would continue to work
to upgrade your job upgrade what you're
making and upgrade what you're doing for
a living while you're finishing up this
degree and think about ways to do things
to move that degree along even faster if
there's something you can do even if you
got an interim associate's degree in
accounting in the two-year mark or
something like that and that would move
you into the accounting field making two
or three times what you're making now
even before you graduate that'd be
something to look towards
you